grab some delicious honey it's time for
our government mandated biannual mark
wahlberg action movie
this time it's infinite which was
supposed to come out theatrically way
back in august of 2020 and then
again in september of 2021 before being
sidelined by paramount plus everyone has
paramount plus right so in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into the
world of
infinite how the reincarnation process
works and i'll answer if this movie was
deserving of a theatrical release
but before we begin make sure to like
and subscribe i'm so close to that 400k
goal and every comment like and
subscription helps infinite begins in
mexico city in the year 1985.
set up by mark wahlberg's voiceover we
learned that there are a group of about
500 individuals on earth who can never
die well they can die but their souls
reincarnated into a new individual
upon death these 500 souls are called
the infinite and within the last 300
years they've split into two factions
on the one hand are the believers who
use their power to help and protect
humanity this faction is led by a man
named treadway who we'll get to in a bit
on the other are the nihilists led by
chiwetel ejiofor's character bathurst
they see their immortality as a curse
and only by destroying humanity can they
be released from this endless
prison after all if there are no bodies
for them to reincarnate into
they can finally be free but back to
mexico city treadway here has
infiltrated bathurst's secret lab and
stolen an item known as the egg a device
which
unspools the very fabric of dna killing
all those around it it's a device that
would completely destroy humanity
and the world he'll end up fighting the
1985 version of bathurst eventually
killed in the process but the big
mystery is
where did the egg go that's what the
2020 version of bathurst has spent the
last 35 or so years looking for the
scientist who made the egg was killed so
a new one couldn't be made so the only
other option is for him to track down
the newly reincarnated version of
treadway
and find out where he put it the film is
really a two-hour long easter egg hunt
the problem is the man who has been
imbued or reincarnated with treadway's
soul doesn't know he has it
at a young age his visions were
misdiagnosed as schizophrenia and he was
put on medication he even tried
committing suicide via car crash which
resulted in him getting a steel plate
inserted into his head
a plot point which becomes pivotal later
on in the film to pay for his medication
evan played here by mark wahlberg who
has the soul of treadway in him
makes samurai swords for local drug
dealers you know normal things
he doesn't quite know how he has this
ability he just knows how to do it
because he was once a japanese
blacksmith in a previous life
he even retains all his knowledge from
those past lives making him a walking
wikipedia
homeboy knows anything you freak but
when the drug deal goes wrong and evan
finds himself running from the cops he's
brought into police custody where
bathurst and the nihilists have tracked
him down
apparently both the nihilists and
believers have an entire network that's
been searching for him and when a
samurai sword forged in a style
unseen since edo japan popped up on
their radars they knew they had a
potential match
the only problem is evan has no idea
about his past even when a gun is pulled
on him notice treadway's ring here which
is the same ring his past-life self wore
in the 1985 intro segment it's only when
evan touches a slingshot from one of his
past lives that he gets a quick
flashback of him as a mayan or aztec
warrior the interrogation is cut short
when nora brightman one of the leaders
of the believers
crashes the party quite literally and
escapes with evan he decides to join her
thinking that this whole event is one
psychotic episode none of this is real
it's a psychotic break is that easier to
believe in the idea that maybe destiny
has something more in store for you
fun easter egg here are the license
plates this one here says reincarnate
and the one from 1985 says infinite
unsuccessful in his attempt at acquiring
the egg we see bathurst being
waterboarded
this has never explained why someone
would want to do this on purpose but the
fact he says
god show me your face leads me to
believe he wants to bring himself closer
to death
in order to get closer to god near the
end of the film when he finally does
acquire the egg he wonders out loud if
god will stop him after all he's about
to destroy the entire planet unlike the
other infinite who develop their
memories of their previous lives as they
grow
older and over time bathurst gets them
all at once as soon as he's developing
in the womb he says the flood of these
memories at once eat away at him and
it's unbearable no wonder he wants to
stop it evan is taken to the hub the
main base of the believers where they
attempt to bring his memories back
now you may think there would be tons of
these infinites around but there aren't
treadway has created a gun-like device
called the dethroner which stores the
soul of its victims restricting them
from entering a new host
essentially he's created a gun that can
lock an infinite in a pseudo-cyber
prison over 200 believers are locked
away in there this is the same gun we
see him use in the intro against a man
named abel nora's partner for hundreds
of years
she tells him to meet her in the
beginning which is their code word for
anchor watt but with abel's soul
imprisoned nora is left to live out the
rest of eternity without her
partner the meeting at the hub also sets
up two important threads
one that treadway had abnormal powers
that no one could understand
he can manipulate the energy of the
world around him this is what evan will
later use to stand upright on the plane
in the final act but other than this
there's no explanation as to why
treadway has this power or where it came
from
second the believers keep the bodies of
their previous hosts and will soon find
out what the real reason for this is
hint it's not to keep as souvenirs the
believers are unable to unlock evan's
memories and must venture to london to
meet a man known as the artisan who
might be able to help
but in order to get them unlocked evan's
brain will need to be jump-started which
can only be done via drowning and
bringing him back to life
it's only when his life literally
flashes before his eyes that he realizes
treadway buried the egg inside his own
body
and conveniently that body is still
stored at the hub
but bathurst says it already sees
control and taken the body with the egg
in it to scotland now it's never
explained why he just doesn't start the
device right here and now probably
because if he did there wouldn't be a
third act so evan and nora go after
bathurst with evan making an
insane motorcycle leaf off a cliff onto
the plane whereby the motorcycle falls
into the engine really just screwing up
bathurst's plans and as evan is about to
destroy the egg which has been put in
this creepy box thing for some reason
he's shot with the dethroner by bathurst
but remember how evan had that steel
plate in his head
the bullet hits and doesn't work which
results in this insane samurai skydiving
battle where
evan stops the bomb and successfully
imprisons bathurst using his own
gun meanwhile the artisan and nora blow
up the imprisoned souls along with a
gravely wounded nora
she fought one of the bathurst minions
and was injured this explosion will
allow those souls to be
released the last we see of evan is him
falling into the ocean from the plane we
aren't sure what happens to him
until the final scene we're in jakarta
indonesia roughly 15 years later
the artisan has tracked down a young boy
with an amazing proficiency for sword
fighting he believes him to be the
reincarnation of treadway which would
mean
evan died and this is confirmed when the
boy says what took you so long
see you soon treadwell but the more
heartwarming ending is nora finally
reuniting with her love with both her
soul
and her partners released by the
explosion in scotland we see
two young people holding hands at angkor
wat or what abel and nora called the
beginning ironic since this is the end
of the movie
now if you want my personal opinion of
the movie it was a total 5 out of 10
action flick that brought nothing new to
the genre it felt like a hodgepodge of
other movies pasted together with no
real intriguing character to root for
so unless you have a paramount plus
account i'd say this movie is a pass
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like subscribe and comment every little
bit helps the channel out
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you